U.S. CITIZENS.
AND DO NOT PUT A BURDEN ON THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE OR WELFARE
SYSTEMS.
IN PART THREE OF OUR REGULATION
NATIONS SERIES, WE LOOK AT
HEALTH CARE.
WHILE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOT TECHNICALLY GOTTEN RID
OF OBAMACARE, CORRESPONDENT
DOUG McKELWAY TELLS US TONIGHT
IT IS GOING AFTER ONE OF ITS
PRIMARY SOURCES OF FUNDING.
>> IN A SIGN OF HOW URGENT IT
WAS, AS THE PARADE WAS WINDING
DOWN, SEVEN HOURS INTO HIS NEW
JOB, THE NEW PRESIDENT NOT
CHANGED INTO HIS TUXEDO, HE
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
DIRECTING AGENCIES TO EASE THE
BURDEN OF OBAMACARE.
IT WAS ONLY SYMBOLIC.
FOLLOWED SIX MONTHS LATER BY AN
ALL TOO REAL DEFEAT AS
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN CAST THE
DECIDING THUMBS DOWN ON REPEAL
OR REPLACE.
NOW TAKING UP A CHISEL WHERE THE
SLEDGEHAMMER FAILED, MR. TRUMP
HAS BEEN CHIPPING AWAY AT
OBAMACARE.
IN OCTOBER, HE SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ALLOWING
INSURERS TO SELL LOW-COST HEALTH
INSURANCE WITH FEWER BENEFITS.
IT TOOK EFFECT TUESDAY.
ALLOWED SMALL BUSINESSES --
AND DIRECTED AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER CHANGES TO HEALTH
REIMBURSEMENT ARRANGEMENTS.
THEY GAVE EMPLOYEES MORE
FLEXIBILITY WITH COMPANY
CONTRIBUTIONS.
SEPARATELY INCLUDING IN THE TAX
BILL WAS THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
REPEAL.
COMBINED THESE ACTIONS MAY SERVE
TO DEPRIVE OBAMACARE OF WHAT IT
MOST NEEDS: YOUNG, HEALTHY
PARTICIPANTS.
>> SUFFERING FROM ADVERSE
SELECTION.
PEOPLE ARE JOINING THE EXCHANGES
IF THEY      THEY ARE HEAVILY SB
IF THEY      THEY ARE HEAVILY SI
IF THEY      THEY ARE HEAVILY SE
IF THEY      THEY ARE HEAVILY SD
OR IF THEY HAVE A HEALTH
CONDITION WHERE THEY CAN GET
PRETTY GOOD PREMIUMS.
>> CRITICS SAY CHIPPING AWAY THE
LAW IS COMING AT A COST.
>> WE HAVE SEEN EFFORTS TO
UNDERMINE COVERAGE.
DRIVING UP PREMIUMS FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS, PEOPLE WITH
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
>> DOES IT MEAN A DEATH SPIRAL
FROM OBAMACARE?
>> THE BASIC STRUCTURE OF THE
LAWS THERE.
>> BECAUSE CONGRESS HASN'T BEEN
WILLING TO STEM ITS FUNDING OF
OBAMACARE LIVES ON.
ALTHOUGH WOUNDED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS BUT THE STROKE OF THE